I really enjoyed
the time I met and researched with you
I don't care if I like it or not I
was able to be urgent with you like I used to
The moment you realize that you like someone, you
fall in love with color.
It's raining like
white
Is it okay oh
[music]
hani He doesn't often force that box
Will you go with me
I can't stay like this forever
If I don't know if I like myself, I don't like it
No, I
like you
ana
I draw conclusions like you do right now
Organize my emotions and take charge of the equation
I decide whether I like you or not I'm a single-minded and hard
worker +142 My heart is extremely strong  Gentle rain 68
Keep yourself well-groomed and never forget to show yourself beautifully and proudly +144 Always stand
out from the crowd and be dignified and dignified
+1244 To me, it's ideal
+1244  You don't let me spoil you on a regular basis
.